in this video we'll talk about histone
variants when we think about histones
these names come in our mind H3 H4 h2a
and h2b these are canonical histones
that are found in all the nucleosomes in
our chromosomes
but alongside these histones there are
many other histone variants
such as h2a z h 3.3 gamma h2x Etc all of
these are not similar to the canonical
histones they differ in few amino acids
and that's make them different and
special
so histone variants confers specific
structural properties that makes them
different from other histones and they
can carry out specialized functions such
as DNA repair chromosome segregation
transcription initiation and also they
might have tissue specific role in this
video we'll talk about these histone
variants so let's build up from Basics
histones are basic proteins having the
amino acids lysine or Arginine they can
be found in the nucleus of the
eukaryotic cell where they are part of
the nucleosome so H3 and H4 forms dimer
eventually h2a and h2b also forms dimer
ultimately they assembles in form of a
tetramar and h3h4 tetramar h2h to be
tetramart together forms the core
histoneokamer and this octamar is
wrapped around by the DNA and that is
called nucleosome the fundamental unit
of a chromatin
now there are several histone variant
types such as H 3.3
this particular variant is highly
enriched in euchromatin and this is
characterized by very high level of
histone acetylation presence of H 3.3 is
strongly correlated with transcription
initiation similarly another variant h2a
Z is actually associated with the
transcription start site and
basically h2az is a variant of h2a
histone and the difference lies in the C
terminal till the other structures are
pretty much same
now Studies have suggested that H 3.3
containing nucleosomes are less stable
so what is the mechanism
it turns out that when there is a
composition of h2a Z and H 3.3 in a
nucleosome the DNA histone interaction
and the histone histone interactions are
now weakened as a result the DNA is
Loosely wrapped around the nucleosome
and sometimes it creates more accessible
chromatin which is more accessible for
transcription Factor binding and thus it
can recruit RNA polymerase and start the
transcription initiation that is why as
a take home message is H 3.3 is
associated with transcriptionally active
chromatin
now question is who deposits H 3.3 in
the nucleosome of actively transcribed
genes there are specific molecules known
as histone chaperones one such example
is the Hira complex that deposits H 3.3
into the euchromatin regions
now question is
how h2a Z is Incorporated in the
chromatin just like H 3.3 there are
specific ATP dependent chromatin
rebodlers that are responsible for the
incorporation of h2se such as P400
family and Sr cap family proteins
actually incorporate h2se in the
nucleosome
so these are both swr1 type of Chromatin
remodeling proteins
so what we learned so far that histone
variant H 3.3 and h2az are mostly
associated with activated genes H 3.3
can be found in several regions like
promoters Gene bodies CIS regulatory
elements and mostly h2se is found in the
promoter region in the start
transcription start site and things
would be more clear if one can look at
the chip sequencing profile of H 3.3 and
h2az one can clearly appreciate that in
the transcription start side there is
the mark for both H 3.3 and h2se however
H 3.3 can be found throughout the gene
body as well so histone chip seek is a
very good method to understand or study
histone variance if you want to learn
more about the basic principles of
chipseek click on the video in the I
button
now let us still tell you that different
type of Chromatin is associated with
different histone variants so if we take
a look at the euchromatin and the
heterochromatin region we would find
variants like h2se and H 3.3 in
euchromatin region whereas the
heterochromatin region would be enriched
in h 3.1 H 3.2 or the centromeric
heterochromatic region would be highly
enriched in Scent a macro h2a these kind
of histone variance so histone variance
is kind of determining the chromatin
accessibility and chromosome state which
is super important to understand gene
expression regulation now there is
another h2a variant known as gamma h2x
which is a novel biomarker for double
stranded DNA brick where there is a
double stranded DNA break gamma h2x is
recruited now gamma h2x along with its
friends such as ATM or ATR kinases
recruit the DNA repair machinery and
this is super important for cell
survivability that is why these histone
variants are really important so in this
video we looked at quite a lot of
histone variants and how they function
differently from the normal histones
besides a structural role they play
defined functional role as well you can
get more notes and flashcards in my
Facebook page you can also follow us on
Instagram to get more notes you can
support our Channel via super thanks and
see you in next video